All kinds of things. So one of the first questions, you know, like the introductory episode was about, like, what actually is good code, what is good, well-designed code, what do we mean? And how do we teach it? And that's a really difficult question to answer, right? And the way I decided to answer that question in the course, the question of how do you actually teach good software design? The only way I came up with that seemed to me worthwhile was to take a leaf out of Welcome to ADSP the podcast, episode 247,
各种各样的事情。所以，第一个问题，你知道，就像介绍性那一集所说的，什么是真正的好代码，什么是设计良好的代码，我们指的是什么？我们该如何教授它？这是一个非常难以回答的问题，对吧？我在课程中决定回答这个问题的方式，即如何真正教授优秀的软件设计？我想到的唯一似乎值得的方法，就是借鉴《欢迎来到 ADSP 播客》第 247 集，
recorded on August 5th, 2025. My name is Connor, and today with my co-host, Ben, we chat about the philosophy of software design and more. Well, now, maybe now is a good time for me to say, sometimes when I listen to you and Bryce the things you say are hilarious. I don't know if it's intentionally hilarious
录制于 2025 年 8 月 5 日。我是 Connor，今天我和我的联合主持人 Ben 一起聊聊软件设计的哲学以及更多内容。好吧，现在也许是时候让我说一句了，有时候当我听你和 Bryce 聊天时，你们说的话真是太搞笑了。我不知道这是否是有意为之的搞笑，
but sometimes I think there's a certain lack of self-awareness but you know I want to be gentle here. You know I laughed out loud when Bryce said oh you know Polish has no word for gelato I'm like
但有时我觉得你们缺乏某种自我意识，你知道，我想在这里说得委婉一点。你知道，当 Bryce 说“哦，你知道波兰语里没有‘意式冰淇淋’（gelato）这个词”时，我笑出了声，我就想，
where do you think the word gelato comes from? It's not English. It's not English is it? Oh yeah. I mean, I, uh, I didn't say it, but I thought, I've been to Poland multiple times, uh, they do have a word for it. It's gelato. Exactly. Yeah.
你觉得 gelato 这个词是从哪儿来的？它不是英语。它不是英语，对吧？哦，是的。我的意思是，我，呃，我没说出来，但我心里想，我去过波兰好多次，呃，他们确实有这个词。就是 gelato。没错。是的。
Um, I understood his point he was making, like, oh, they don't, they don't, they don't, yeah, they have one for ice cream, but not for gelato, but like, English doesn't have a word either. Yeah, yeah. If you've been to other countries around the world, they just call it gelato everywhere. I mean, I, I'm sure there's a couple languages. that put a little spin on the word gelato. Yeah, I, I didn't say any. There's a lot of times when Bryce is saying some stuff,
嗯，我明白他想表达的意思，就像，“哦，他们没有，他们没有，他们有冰淇淋（ice cream）的词，但没有 gelato 的词”，但英语里也没有这个词啊。是的，是的。如果你去过世界上的其他国家，他们到处都叫它 gelato。我的意思是，我肯定有几种语言对 gelato 这个词做了一点点变体。是的，我，我没说什么。有很多时候 Bryce 说了一些话，
and I kind of just am like, there's no reason for me to point this out. But I'm glad that you laugh. I'd be curious if there's other moments that you can recall off the top of your head. Oh, in that same episode, he said he was bad at pronunciation. And I'm like, yeah, you are. I was a, that was another heller, but, you know.
我只是觉得，我没必要指出这一点。但我很高兴你笑了。我很好奇你还能不能随口说出其他类似的时刻。哦，在同一集里，他说他不擅长发音。我就想，是的，你确实不擅长。那是另一个笑点，但是，你知道。
Yeah, I was, I was, I spent quite a bit of work getting that intro because I actually hadn't started recording and I had to get Bryce to share permissions to the team's recording so that I could get my audio because it was just hilarious when he was like all right, we're going. And I was like, what?
是的，我，我花了不少功夫才搞定那个开场，因为我当时还没开始录音，我不得不让 Bryce 分享 Teams 录音的权限，这样我才能拿到我的音频，因为当他说“好了，我们开始吧”的时候，那真是太搞笑了。而我当时就想，什么？
It's like, that's not an even Polish. That's closer to German or something like that. And Shima actually speaks a little bit of Polish too and she knew how to say Chesh and I had no idea she spoke any Polish and she was like Oh, yeah, like that, very far off. But maybe there'll be an app for him soon that he can do that are used that's better than dualingo. And someone actually, yeah, that's a callback.
那甚至都不是波兰语。那更接近德语之类的。而且 Shima 其实也会说一点波兰语，她知道怎么说“你好”（Cześć），我根本不知道她会说波兰语，她说“哦，是的，就像那样”，差得太远了。但也许很快就会有一款比多邻国（Duolingo）更好的应用程序供他使用。而且有人确实，是的，这是一个呼应。
Someone did point out that there is an app called Speak that is trying to reinvent the space. Like I said in the podcast, like there's a, it's a ripe for disruption because most of them just teach you vocab and it's not that great. And apparently Speak is that. And they started in Korea as an English teaching app. And then they're massive in South Korea now. And they're branching out to other languages, but currently Farsi or Persian is not on the app. I mean, I thought you might have an interesting take here
有人确实指出有一款叫 Speak 的应用程序正在试图重塑这个领域。就像我在播客里说的，这个领域已经成熟，等待被颠覆，因为大多数应用只是教你词汇，而且效果并不好。显然 Speak 就是那样。他们最初在韩国作为一款英语教学应用起家。现在他们在韩国非常受欢迎。他们正在扩展到其他语言，但目前波斯语（Farsi）不在该应用中。我的意思是，我觉得你可能会有有趣的见解，
because you at one time worked in China and you certainly spoke Mandarin pretty well, like, what do we say, 10 years ago? Yeah, 12, 12 years to be, or 13 to be exact? Anyways, just over 10 years, yeah. So I was surprised that you didn't actually bring up learning language from humans over the internet, right? Because all these apps, they're fine, but certainly once you get to a certain level, I would much rather get lessons from a native speaker, right? I would go with duolingo or Rosetta Stone or whatever, up to a certain point.
因为你曾经在中国工作过，而且你 10 年前肯定说得一口流利的普通话，对吧？是的，准确地说是 12 年，或者 13 年？总之，刚过 10 年，是的。所以我很惊讶你竟然没有提到通过互联网向人类学习语言，对吧？因为所有这些应用程序，它们还可以，但一旦你达到一定水平，我宁愿从母语人士那里获得课程，对吧？我会选择多邻国或罗塞塔石碑（Rosetta Stone）之类的，直到达到某个点，
but there's no substitute for, you know, talking to real people, I think. Yes. And, you know, there's, there are several sites now. Italky is one I'm aware of, and there are, I'm sure, others, where you can just go on the site, sign up, get lessons in whatever language you like from whatever native speaker tutor is on there. Yeah. Uh, 100% agree.
但我觉得，没有什么能替代与真人交谈。是的。而且，你知道，现在有几个网站。Italki 是我知道的一个，我相信还有其他网站，你可以在上面注册，从上面的任何母语导师那里学习你喜欢的任何语言。是的。呃，100% 同意。
I mean, I think implicitly I kind of said that by saying, as soon as you go to the country and you're immersed, you know, it just sky rockets. Yeah. But if you can't go to the country, you know, like many of us can't just drop things, go to a country to learn a language.
我的意思是，我觉得我通过说“一旦你去了那个国家并沉浸其中，你的水平就会突飞猛进”已经隐含地表达了这一点。是的。但如果你不能去那个国家，你知道，像我们许多人一样，不能放下一切去一个国家学习语言。
And also, you know, there are lots of languages you might want to learn where you don't particularly want to live in the country, or at least not for an extended time, right? So, you know, like when I was at school, I studied French. Because I'm English. you know, that is the standard foreign language that everyone in England learns as a high schooler, as a middle schooler.
而且，你知道，有很多你想学的语言，你并不特别想住在那个国家，或者至少不想住很长时间，对吧？所以，你知道，就像我在学校时，我学了法语。因为我是英国人。你知道，那是英国每个中学生、初中生都会学的标准外语。
And so by the time I graduated from high school, equivalent of, I was pretty fluent in French. You know, like, we had a standing homework which was to record the news bulletin from France Antaire, which you can receive in the south of England on a long wave or could. So I would record that every week and translate it. That was our standing homework, right? And so by the time I graduated high school, I was pretty fluent in French. I've lost it now. But I did go, during the pandemic, I went back and I went to I talkie and I booked a couple of lessons.
所以当我高中毕业时，相当于，我的法语已经相当流利了。你知道，我们有固定的家庭作业，就是录制法国国际广播电台（France Inter）的新闻简报，在英格兰南部可以通过长波接收到，或者曾经可以。所以我每周都会录下来并翻译它。那是我们固定的家庭作业，对吧？所以当我高中毕业时，我的法语相当流利。现在我已经丢掉了。但在疫情期间，我回去过，我去了 Italki 并预订了几节课。
And the great thing was I could choose, you know, what kind of French do I want to learn? This tutor is speaking French and they're from Paris. This speaker is from Montreal, right? This other speaker is from Senegal. So you can choose kind of which variety of the language you want to learn and you can get a tutor that matches you. And I found that really good. Yeah. No, 100%.
最棒的是我可以选择，你知道，我想学哪种法语？这位导师说法语，他们来自巴黎。这位演讲者来自蒙特利尔，对吧？这位演讲者来自塞内加尔。所以你可以选择你想学习哪种语言变体，并找到适合你的导师。我觉得这非常好。是的，100%。
I hadn't heard of that website, but there are definitely a bunch of websites. Some of them specialize in just a specific language, which was the one that I tried out that one time. But yeah, 100% agree. I mean, I forgot a bunch of things that I should have mentioned. Someone pointed out, it was either Mastodon or Blue Sky. I can't remember which one. But someone said, I'm surprised you didn't mention watching television shows in that language. Yeah.
我没听说过那个网站，但肯定有很多网站。其中一些专门针对特定语言，那是我曾经尝试过的一个。但是的，100% 同意。我的意思是，我忘记了一些我应该提到的事情。有人指出，是在 Mastodon 或 Blue Sky 上，我不记得是哪一个了。但有人说，我很惊讶你没有提到观看该语言的电视节目。是的。
And I just had this kind of like face palm moment because there is, I think I've mentioned it at some point on this podcast. There is a specifically in China or in Chinese is an amazing show for learning Chinese called Fei Chung U Rao, which is imagine the X factor combined with the Bachelorette that resets every 15 minutes. So there's like 20 women on stage, each with an X-Factor button in booth. And they bring out guys one at a time. And, you know, in the show, who knows how it is in real life. But it's about 15 minutes on the show where he comes out, he introduces himself. And at any point during the segment, the girl can hit the X button to say she's not interested. So I've never seen either of those shows.
我当时有一种拍额头的时刻，因为有一个，我想我在这个播客的某个时候提到过。有一个特别是在中国，或者用中文，有一个非常棒的学中文节目叫《非诚勿扰》，想象一下《X音素》（X Factor）结合《单身女郎》（The Bachelorette），每 15 分钟重置一次。舞台上有 20 位女性，每人都有一个 X 按钮和展位。他们一次带一个男嘉宾出来。而且，你知道，在节目里，谁知道现实生活中是什么样。但节目中大约 15 分钟，他出来，介绍自己。在这一段的任何时候，女孩都可以按下 X 按钮表示她不感兴趣。所以我从来没看过这两个节目。
So you can have to explain to me how they work. X-Factor is like three judges with an X where it's kind of like an odd. You know, they come out with some kind of talent or singing, and if they don't like it, they hit the X. Okay. The Bachelor et is one, or the Bachelor, I guess, is one guy, and then end girls, and, you know, one of them, and they end up together at the end,
所以你得向我解释它们是怎么运作的。《X音素》就像三个评委，有一个 X，这有点像个怪事。你知道，他们带着某种才艺或唱歌出来，如果他们不喜欢，他们就按 X。好的。《单身女郎》，或者《单身汉》，我想，是一个男人，然后是 N 个女孩，你知道，其中一个，他们最后在一起，
and it's just one of the romance reality shows. So if you combine those, there's a bunch of women, each with an X button slash booth, and then one guy. And the reason it's great. I mean, say what you will about the show. It's quite entertaining because, you know, they have different characters that come on,
这只是浪漫真人秀节目之一。所以如果你把它们结合起来，有一群女性，每人都有一个 X 按钮/展位，然后是一个男人。它之所以棒，是因为，随你怎么评价这个节目。它相当有趣，因为，你知道，他们有不同的角色出现，
in terms of the guys. And then sometimes, if they're not attracted to them initially, like half the girls will just hit the X and then it's kind of awkward because, you know, that's usually bad. Ideally, you want them not to hit the X. Don't judge a book by its cover. Yeah, yeah, exactly. But the reason it's great is that, one, it resets every 15 minutes.
就男嘉宾而言。有时，如果她们最初对他们不感兴趣，一半的女孩就会直接按 X，然后气氛会有点尴尬，因为，你知道，这通常很糟糕。理想情况下，你希望她们不要按 X。不要以貌取人。是的，是的，完全正确。但它之所以棒，是因为，第一，它每 15 分钟重置一次。
It's like an hour-long show, so you'll see three or four different guys. And if you get lost at some point, you just got to wait five minutes and then it's going to be a new person. The other reason is it's all, hi, my name is, you know, I live in. this city my job is starting out conversational yeah and and towards the end of the 15 minute segment they do start to talk about their hobbies and i like to dance or i like to fly airplanes and so you do get to learn new vocabulary it like it always starts off very easy if you're just learning the language and so it's it's a great show like a lot a lot of times people recommend
这是一个一小时的节目，所以你会看到三四个不同的男人。如果你在某个时候迷失了，你只需要等五分钟，就会有新人出现。另一个原因是，这全是，“嗨，我叫，你知道，我住在，这个城市，我的工作是”，从对话开始，是的，在 15 分钟片段的最后，他们确实开始谈论他们的爱好，我喜欢跳舞，或者我喜欢开飞机，所以你确实能学到新词汇，它总是从非常简单开始，如果你只是在学习这门语言，所以这是一个很棒的节目，很多时候人们推荐，
you some you know the equivalent of like friends or the big bang theory but like you're going to get lost so quickly and you're not going to understand what's going on unless if you have English subtitles, which I don't recommend. Anyway, so that is another fantastic way that, you know, it doesn't, you can find a lot of these shows online for free. Like, Fechengu Rao, it's on YouTube. You can get all the episodes. And the other one is if you have a, if you live with someone like Embrice's case,
你，你知道，相当于《老友记》或《生活大爆炸》之类的，但你会很快迷失，除非你有英文字幕，否则你不会明白发生了什么，我不推荐那样。总之，这是另一种绝妙的方法，你知道，它不需要，你可以在网上免费找到很多这样的节目。比如《非诚勿扰》，它在 YouTube 上。你可以找到所有的剧集。另一个是如果你有，如果你和某人住在一起，比如 Bryce 的情况，
a cousin of mine who lives in Montreal with his partner, he would alternate days in English and French. And he is not just fluent in French now, but like most people don't realize that he didn't speak. French to begin with because his accent is so good. But it takes a lot of effort, right? There's a struggle at the beginning when you're trying to do French all one day. Yeah, to get a halfway good accent, you need to be in some way immersed.
我的一位表亲和他的伴侣住在蒙特利尔，他会交替使用英语和法语。他现在不仅法语流利，而且大多数人都没有意识到他一开始并不会说法语，因为他的口音太好了。但这需要付出很多努力，对吧？当你试图整天说法语时，一开始会有挣扎。是的，要获得相当不错的口音，你需要以某种方式沉浸其中。
I was, you know, living in England, I had teachers who were fluent in French and German, and in some cases were themselves French. So I was able to get a pretty good accent. And, of course, I was consuming actual French media. Right. So I was able to, my accent's pretty good. Although these days, I'm super rusty. Like, when I went onto the site and got a, got a lesson,
我当时，你知道，住在英国，我的老师法语和德语都很流利，在某些情况下他们本身就是法国人。所以我能够获得相当不错的口音。当然，我当时在接触真正的法语媒体。对。所以我能够，我的口音相当不错。虽然这些天，我非常生疏。就像，当我上那个网站并上了一节课时，
the teacher was really nice. And she said, you know, it's strange, some kind of, some vocabulary, some strange vocabulary stays with you, right? the kind of thing he was getting vocabulary tests as a kid when I last met my French teacher I said to him
老师人非常好。她说，你知道，这很奇怪，一些词汇，一些奇怪的词汇会留在你的脑海里，对吧？就像我小时候做词汇测试一样，当我上次见到我的法语老师时，我对他说，
you're still the reason I will never confuse a steering wheel and the shutter you know because in French those words can be confused at least to English speakers
你仍然是我永远不会混淆“方向盘”和“百叶窗”的原因，你知道，因为在法语中，这些词可能会被混淆，至少对英语使用者来说是这样，
but yeah so what I've lost is the fluency I so my when I speak it's halting I'm no longer thinking in French right that's what you lose that's the first thing you
但是的，所以我失去的是流利度，所以当我说话时，它是断断续续的，我不再用法语思考了，对吧？这就是你失去的东西，那是你失去的第一件事，
these yeah um but uh but yeah if if you can drop someone in a country after three weeks four weeks of immersion i think i think you know they they they pick that up yeah it'll it'll skyrocket for sure look at that a second mini episode on uh learning language is french the only language uh that you've well i said so in school i studied i have a german gccc although i don't remember that much of it. I never really cared to learn all of the different ways that prepositions take different cases. French is the main thing I learned. I learned Latin as well, but again, that was by the side. But French was the thing where I learned it and I learned it over a fairly long period. Like, I had a good 10 years of French. I did French GCSC.S.E. I did
这些，是的，嗯，但是，呃，但是是的，如果，如果你能把一个人扔到一个国家，经过三周、四周的沉浸，我想，我想，你知道，他们，他们，他们会学会的，是的，它肯定会突飞猛进。看，关于学习语言的第二个迷你剧集，法语是你学过的唯一语言吗？嗯，我说了，在学校里我学过，我有一个德语 GCSE，虽然我不记得太多了。我从来没真正关心过学习介词如何采用不同格的所有不同方式。法语是我学的主要东西。我也学过拉丁语，但同样，那只是副业。但法语是我学习它并经过相当长一段时间学习的东西。比如，我学了整整 10 年的法语。我参加了法语 GCSE。我参加了，
French AS level. G.C.S.E and AS, these are, I think, UK terms? Yeah. So G. G. G. G. CCSE is you take that in a sophomore year of high school when you're 16 and A levels of kind of like university entrance exams, you take them when you're senior year. AS level is same standard as A level. It counts for like half. It's basically speaking in the case of French when I took it, it was speaking and reading and fluency, but no literature component. So we didn't have to study Victor Hugo or anything like that, but we did, you know, totally listen to French radio. Interesting. Yeah, that is probably preferable if you're just trying to learn how to converse. Yeah. And not necessarily.
法语 AS 水平。GCSE 和 AS，这些是，我想，英国的术语？是的。所以 GCSE 是你在高中二年级 16 岁时参加的，A-level 有点像大学入学考试，你在高三时参加。AS 水平与 A-level 标准相同。它算作一半。基本上，在我参加法语考试时，它是口语、阅读和流利度，但没有文学部分。所以我们不必学习维克多·雨果之类的东西，但我们确实，你知道，完全听了法语广播。有趣。是的，如果你只是想学习如何交谈，那可能更可取。是的。而不一定是。
Although I'd have to say, you should read French literature as well because it's something's really good. You can read it in English translations, but. Can you read in French now still? I think it's charitable to say no. You know, haltingly, to read an actual book or a newspaper article, there'd be bits of vocabulary I don't know. So I'd have to say no. But I still, you know, you can get an English translation alongside a French translation. And if you have reasonable French, then it makes sense to read the French and when you need to cross-reference.
虽然我不得不说，你也应该阅读法语文学，因为它真的很棒。你可以读英译本，但是。你现在还能用法语阅读吗？我觉得说“不能”比较客观。你知道，断断续续地，读一本真正的书或报纸文章，会有一些我不认识的词汇。所以我不得不说不能。但我仍然，你知道，你可以找一本英译本对照法语译本。如果你有合理的法语水平，那么阅读法语并在需要时交叉参考是有意义的。
Right, right. Yeah, I remember when I was learning. Chinese, there was a really good website where they had popular novels. The one that I read was Narnia, Twanxi, which was I'm probably terribly
对，对。是的，我记得我学习中文时，有一个非常好的网站，上面有流行小说。我读的那本是《纳尼亚传奇》（Narnia），这可能是，我可能非常，
messed up the tones there, but it's Chronicles of Narnia. It was great because it would show you the, in Chinese, the text, but if you didn't know a word, you could hover over it and it would basically give you the English one. So it's kind of like an interactive way to
搞砸了那里的声调，但那是《纳尼亚传奇》。这很棒，因为它会向你展示中文文本，但如果你不知道一个词，你可以把鼠标悬停在上面，它基本上会给你英语翻译。所以这有点像一种交互式的方式，
progressively learn how read which is quite nice that like you can imagine you're trying to read something and I think in Kindles they have the ability to like define words that you don't know you know you hit on it yeah you can define a look up in a dictionary so it's the same kind of thing but just for translation and that was a really good tool all right anyway so we've talked about AI we've gotten your thoughts and we've talked a little bit about learning languages and a couple other topics um where should go from me here i mean i've kind of been dictating uh have you got topics i know i know we mentioned c++ now if we want to if you're there or
逐步学习如何阅读，这非常好，你可以想象你试图阅读某样东西，我想在 Kindle 中，他们有定义你不认识的单词的能力，你知道，你点击它，是的，你可以定义一个字典查询，所以这是同样的事情，只是用于翻译，那是一个非常好的工具。好吧，总之，我们谈论了人工智能，我们了解了你的想法，我们还谈论了一点关于学习语言和其他几个话题，嗯，我们接下来该去哪儿？我的意思是，我一直在主导，你有话题吗？我知道，我知道我们提到了 C++，现在如果我们想的话，如果你在那里，或者，
Are there other topics on your stack of... A little... I mean, a lot of what I've been putting brain power into these last few months is I've been giving a course in software design at work. Oh. So, and how to design functions, APIs, types, all of the above. You know, the course has been fairly wide-ranging. It's been very interesting.
你的堆栈里还有其他话题吗……一点点……我的意思是，过去几个月我投入脑力最多的事情是我在工作中开设了一门软件设计课程。哦。所以，以及如何设计函数、API、类型，所有这些。你知道，这门课程范围相当广泛。非常有趣。
This week is actually the final... the final one. There have been 12 of them. So it's been quite the undertaking. It's been really interesting. I think it's been really valuable. It's been hard work for me. It turns out it's really difficult to distill thoughts on, like, and it's the thing of
这周实际上是最后一节……最后一节。总共有 12 节。所以这是一项相当大的工程。这真的很有趣。我觉得它非常有价值。对我来说这很辛苦。事实证明，提炼关于，比如，的想法真的很难，而且这是关于，
like, you know, we know beautiful code when we see it, but how can we teach people what good code design looks like? So those are the kind of questions I've been wrestling with. I imagine you, so this is a fantastic, I had no idea about. this is a fantastic topic to talk about software design and it immediately makes me think of the fact that uh shan parent that adobe is also he with his reincarnation of the st lab um has been also i think with friends at the company teaching a course which i think is called better code in symmetry with his upcoming at some point book um and has given i'm really still waiting for
就像，你知道，我们看到漂亮的代码时就知道它是漂亮的，但我们如何教人们什么是好的代码设计？所以这些是我一直在纠结的问题。我想你，所以这是一个很棒的，我完全不知道。这是一个谈论软件设计的好话题，它立刻让我想到了这样一个事实，呃，Adobe 的 Sean Parent，他带着他重生的 ST 库，也一直在，我想，和公司的朋友们教授一门课程，我想这门课程叫“更好的代码”，与他即将出版的书相呼应，而且已经给出了，我真的还在等，
that book that book's been upcoming for a while i'm hoping that sean gets time to finish yet. Yeah, I think he's been, the last time we chatted it, he said he was been spending more time, you know, getting the videos out, which correspond to the, you know, chapters of the textbook. And we'll link a couple of them in the show notes that he's given talks at different conferences called, you know, better code, colon, insert a chapter of the book. I bring that up because the first question is, is all, is this stuff publicly available in terms of slides or recordings anywhere? No. No, it's an internal course. But, you know, some of the same thinking makes its way at times into some of my conference talks. I see. And is this,
那本书，那本书已经预告很久了，我希望 Sean 有时间完成它。是的，我想他一直，上次我们聊天时，他说他一直在花更多时间，你知道，制作视频，这些视频对应于，你知道，教科书的章节。我们会在节目笔记中链接几个他在不同会议上发表的演讲，题目是，你知道，“更好的代码”，冒号，插入书中的一章。我提到这一点是因为第一个问题是，所有这些东西在幻灯片或录音方面是否公开可用？不。不，这是一门内部课程。但是，你知道，一些相同的想法有时会出现在我的一些会议演讲中。我明白了。这是，
is this a one-time thing at Intel or is this something that you plan to do potentially in the future? Well, you know, in a sense that part of my job is helping to level up the teams that I'm on. That, that aspect continues. In terms of this course, I am glad to have done it. And I'm not in the market for spending a huge amount of brain power doing another course right now. But it's been great. It's been really good. Would it be, if you ever did it down the road after taking a hiatus from doing the course as obvious as a lot of work, would it be something that, or is it, would it be something
这是英特尔的一次性事件，还是你计划在未来可能做的事情？嗯，你知道，从某种意义上说，我工作的一部分是帮助提升我所在团队的水平。那个方面还在继续。就这门课程而言，我很高兴完成了它。而且我现在没有兴趣花费大量的脑力去开设另一门课程。但这很棒。这真的很好。如果未来在休息一段时间后，你再次开设这门课程，因为这显然是一项繁重的工作，它会是，或者它会是，
that, you know, would ever be recorded similar to the A9 or Adobe stuff, or is it too much internal? For this particular course, there's not a whole lot of internal. content like there's nothing particularly secret in it most and indeed when it comes to actually talking about code most of the examples come from our open source libraries that i work on um as you as you sort of may expect that's that's fairly commonly the case that i've reached those for examples so yeah there's no a priori reason why something like this should not be public i I suppose.
你知道，会被录制下来，类似于 A9 或 Adobe 的东西，还是太内部了？对于这门特定的课程，没有太多内部内容，比如里面没有什么特别秘密的东西，而且事实上，当谈到真正谈论代码时，大多数例子来自我工作的开源库，嗯，正如你可能预料的那样，这相当常见，我经常引用那些作为例子，所以是的，没有先验理由说明这样的东西不应该公开，我想。
But, you know, it swings in roundabouts, right? Because it's not public, actually, when I give the talks internally, I get to sort of tailor it to the audience a bit more, which is helpful as well. Yeah, and of course, if you're, if you would record the lectures or the talks, it's obviously going to affect the willingness of participants. to speak up and ask questions if they know it's being recorded. Right. So there's obviously trade-offs.
但是，你知道，有得必有失，对吧？因为它不是公开的，实际上，当我内部进行演讲时，我可以根据听众进行一些调整，这也有帮助。是的，当然，如果你录制讲座或演讲，这显然会影响参与者在知道被录音的情况下发言和提问的意愿。对。所以显然有权衡。
I mean, exciting to hear that you're doing that kind of thing. So, I mean, can you give an overview of, you said there's 12 different talks or, are you calling them talks, lectures? It's a series of 12, and really it's 12 because, I think because after I'd done this many, I got, I kind of got to the point where I'm like, 12 seems like a good number to finish it off and I wanted to be finished. But we cover, we'll cover, we'll
我的意思是，听到你在做那种事情很令人兴奋。所以，我的意思是，你能概述一下吗，你说有 12 个不同的演讲，或者，你称它们为演讲，讲座？这是一个 12 节的系列，之所以是 12 节，是因为，我想是因为在我做了这么多之后，我，我有点到了那种地步，我想，12 似乎是一个很好的数字来结束它，而且我想结束它。但我们涵盖，我们将涵盖，我们，
kinds of things. So one of the first questions, you know, like the introductory episode was about like what actually is good code, what is good, well-designed code, what do we mean, and how do we teach it? And that's a really difficult question to answer, right? And the way I decided to answer that question in the course, the question of how do you actually teach good software design? The only way I came up with that seemed to me worthwhile was to take a leaf out of non-software designs book, right, to look at other things in the world, like graphic design or like, you know, any kind of creative endeavor where design is a part. And in almost all cases, the way your own design skills is through critique, right? So it's not enough just to say,
各种各样的事情。所以第一个问题，你知道，就像介绍性那一集所说的，什么是真正的好代码，什么是设计良好的代码，我们指的是什么，我们该如何教授它？这是一个非常难以回答的问题，对吧？我在课程中决定回答这个问题的方式，即如何真正教授优秀的软件设计？我想到的唯一似乎值得的方法，就是借鉴非软件设计的书，对吧，去看看世界上其他的东西，比如图形设计，或者，你知道，任何设计作为一部分的创造性努力。在几乎所有情况下，你自己的设计技能是通过批评来获得的，对吧？所以仅仅说，
oh, you know, this is good, or here's an example of good. But we have to, you know, so one of the The things we did in the course was look at different APIs and critique them and say, you know, what when the author wrote this, what were they thinking? What do we think they had in mind, right? And what use cases do they have in mind and what requirements did they have and what constraints did they have? And then, you know, if we were to sit down and write this same API now, would we make the same choices? What are the choices? You know, what are the axes of variation that we can identify? you know just the simple act of sort of kind of identifying the design space of the code is is one important thing to do right and and it's important to really think broadly about that and to think about that in a way that is not as much as possible thinking about implementation and it is so hard you know for engineers like us because we're so used to implementing right as soon as we see a problem we think oh I know how to do that. I know how to solve that. I know how to implement that. Just type, type, type. I can have an implementation.
哦，你知道，这是好的，或者这是一个好的例子，是不够的。但我们必须，你知道，所以我们在课程中所做的事情之一就是查看不同的 API 并批评它们，说，你知道，当作者写这个时，他们在想什么？我们认为他们心里有什么，对吧？他们考虑了什么用例，他们有什么要求，他们有什么约束？然后，你知道，如果我们现在坐下来编写同一个 API，我们会做出同样的选择吗？选择是什么？你知道，我们可以识别出的变化轴是什么？你知道，仅仅是识别代码设计空间的简单行为就是一件重要的事情，对吧，而且非常广泛地思考这一点，并以尽可能少地思考实现的方式来思考这一点，这很重要。这对于像我们这样的工程师来说太难了，因为我们太习惯于实现了，对吧？一旦我们看到一个问题，我们就会想，哦，我知道怎么做。我知道怎么解决它。我知道怎么实现它。只要打字，打字，打字。我可以有一个实现。
But no, the trick with design is to say, let me assume that this can be implemented. I don't care about the implementation today. I'm not wearing that hat, right? There will be a time when I wear that hat. But that is not today. Today, I'm saying, what's the design? What are the, like I said, axes of variation?
但不，设计的诀窍是说，让我假设这可以被实现。我今天不关心实现。我今天没戴那顶帽子，对吧？会有我戴那顶帽子的时候。但不是今天。今天，我说，设计是什么？正如我所说的，变化轴是什么？
How are these things going to be used? How are they going to be composed? Thoughts like that. And it's also kind of. of expanding our horizons there sometimes one of the things I like to is like ask absurd questions you know and particularly having studied multiple computer languages sort of helps expand your ideas there so you think so you think of things like well what if i you know what if in c++ what if i couldn't use functions what if i only could use lambdas right no such
这些东西将如何被使用？它们将如何被组合？诸如此类的想法。而且这也是一种拓宽我们视野的方法，有时我喜欢做的事情之一就是问荒谬的问题，你知道，特别是学习多种计算机语言有助于扩展你的想法，所以你思考，所以你思考诸如，好吧，如果我，你知道，如果用 C++，如果我不能使用函数，如果我只能使用 lambda，对吧？没有这样的，
things as a function well what if you know what what things have to live at compile time what things have to live at runtime, you know, what if I can't use this construct, what if I only can use this construct, what, you know, sort of absurdities? Like, what if, what if no functions ever returned and all they ever did was pass on a continuation? There's a style of coding that we almost never do in C++, but, you know, thinking about that really helps you think about senders, for example. So there are all sorts of different kind of, I don't know, know, techniques I tried to come up with, just kind of examining how I think about code and how people I have worked with who I have seen what they can do. So I've learned from them. And I tried to
函数之类的东西，好吧，如果，你知道，什么东西必须在编译时存在，什么东西必须在运行时存在，你知道，如果我不能使用这个结构，如果我只能使用那个结构，什么，你知道，某种荒谬？比如，如果，如果没有任何函数返回，它们所做的只是传递一个延续？这是一种我们在 C++ 中几乎从不使用的编码风格，但是，你知道，思考这一点真的有助于你思考发送者（senders），例如。所以有各种各样不同的，我不知道，技巧，我试图想出，只是检查我如何思考代码，以及我见过的人，我见过他们能做什么。所以我从他们那里学到了。我试图，
I tried to put all these things into a course. And along the way, we did some API critiques, like I said, because that's a great way to really one of the ways to hone a kind of design sensibility is by reading other code and thinking about it deeply and critiquing it. But we also studied, you know, we studied patterns, we studied some practical things about how can we design functions, how can they be more or less composable, how does that scale up to APIs and types and objects, and how do we test things? You know, that was one of the one of the sessions so i mean it sounds like a certain percentage of this course is almost like the philosophy of good software design is it yeah is that true would you agree with that i mean
我试图把所有这些东西放进一门课程中。在此过程中，我们做了一些 API 批评，就像我说的，因为这是真正磨练一种设计敏感性的好方法，通过阅读其他代码并深入思考和批评它。但我们也研究了，你知道，我们研究了模式，我们研究了一些关于我们如何设计函数的实际事情，它们如何变得或多或少可组合，这如何扩展到 API、类型和对象，以及我们如何测试东西？你知道，那是其中一个环节，所以我的意思是，听起来这门课程的某个百分比几乎就像是优秀软件设计的哲学，是吗？是这样吗？你会同意吗？我的意思是，
that certainly was how i pitched it in the introduction and the the coda um sessions because because yeah um design is about it it's separate from implementation right that's one of the things that we're trying to present here. It's one of the things we're trying to say. Like, you can get a problem to solve and you can go ahead and implement something and solve it. And, you know, Alice can do that. Bob can do that.
这当然是我在介绍和尾声环节中推销它的方式，因为，因为是的，嗯，设计是关于它的，它与实现是分开的，对吧？这是我们试图在这里展示的事情之一。这是我们试图说的事情之一。比如，你可以得到一个问题来解决，你可以继续实现一些东西并解决它。而且，你知道，Alice 可以做到。Bob 可以做到。
Charlie can do that. They can all code up implementations that fulfill the criteria, that fulfill the requirements, that adhere to the constraints, that pass all of the tests. But then we can look at those three different implementations. and they will be differently designed.
Charlie 可以做到。他们都可以编写出满足标准、满足要求、遵守约束、通过所有测试的实现。但随后我们可以看看那三种不同的实现。它们的设计会有所不同。
They will be, you know, one might be ugly. One might be beautiful. One might be somewhere in between. How do we quantify that in a sense? How do we characterize that? How do we know that code is ugly versus beautiful? You know, and it's about looking beyond what today's problem is. and it's about looking to
它们会是，你知道，一个可能很丑。一个可能很美。一个可能介于两者之间。我们如何从某种意义上量化它？我们如何表征它？我们怎么知道代码是丑陋的还是美丽的？你知道，这是关于超越今天的问题。这是关于展望，
you know how will things change in the future is this code uh changeable malleable understandable properties like that very interesting I mean it sounds not dissimilar to
你知道，未来事情会如何变化，这段代码是可变的、可塑的、可理解的吗？诸如此类的属性。非常有趣。我的意思是，听起来与，
a couple talks are they the same or they talk about tangentially similar topics there was one that Titus Winders is given about I think it was software engineering versus programming or he has some kind of quote around that you know that programming software engineering
几个演讲不太一样，它们是相同的，还是它们谈论的是切线相似的话题？有一个 Titus Winters 给出的演讲，关于我想是软件工程与编程，或者他围绕那个有一些引言，你知道，编程，软件工程，
is programming plus time or something like that integrated over time yeah yeah integrated over time and then david sankle he gave a talk a couple years ago at a c++ now that was looking at the software engineering from the perspective of other engineering domains was kind of like what can we learn from you know actual civil or mechanical engineers and stuff and, you know, engineers that have bodies of whatever professional organizations behind them that have a lot more, not weight behind them, but, you know, they have codes of ethics and whatnot and things like rules they have to abide by, whereas we don't really have that, at least at this point in time. Yeah, and there are a couple of thoughts there, you know, to tie back to our earlier discussion about AI coding, like one of the problems right now is that AI can't take responsibility for the code, right? the program has to take responsibility. And, you know, if you're working in a field where your code could result in harm to humans
是编程加时间，或者类似的东西，随时间积分，对吧，随时间积分，然后 David Sankel，他在几年前的 C++ Now 上做了一个演讲，从其他工程领域的角度审视软件工程，有点像我们可以从，你知道，实际的土木或机械工程师等身上学到什么，而且，你知道，有某种专业组织支持的工程师，他们有更多的，不是支持，但，你知道，他们有道德准则之类的东西，以及他们必须遵守的规则，而我们并没有真正拥有那个，至少在目前。是的，那里有几个想法，你知道，回到我们之前关于 AI 编码的讨论，比如现在的问题之一是 AI 不能对代码负责，对吧？程序员必须承担责任。而且，你知道，如果你在一个代码可能导致人类伤害的领域工作，
or loss of livelihood or even of life, that's a very serious ethical concern, I think. You know, this is something I feel every day. I work on code that goes into chips that are used. for everything right you know including you know computerized operating theatres for instance because because we don't you know we don't we don't we don't just make objects anymore as a society we make computers we what's the quote we don't we don't drive cars or fly planes we have computers that with wheels and computers with wings and you know computers that we use to to heal people
或生计损失，甚至生命损失，我认为这是一个非常严重的道德问题。你知道，这是我每天都能感受到的。我从事的代码进入了芯片，这些芯片被用于，一切，对吧，你知道，包括，你知道，计算机化的手术室，例如，因为，因为我们不，你知道，我们不，我们不，我们不只是制造对象，作为一个社会，我们制造计算机，我们，那句名言是什么，我们不，我们不驾驶汽车或飞行飞机，我们有带轮子的计算机和带翅膀的计算机，你知道，我们用来治愈人的计算机，
and it's when i took this job a few years ago now and even when i took my previous job that was something that i sort of felt quite strongly um you know i came from the games industry in the games industry if you screw up it doesn't matter that much um but But if you're working in, really, it doesn't. That's not to say that, you know, the game industry is a hard job and a worthwhile job. But at the end of the day, it doesn't have the same kind of ethical concerns around it. Yeah. As if you're shipping code that could lose millions of dollars in seconds
而且，当我几年前接受这份工作时，甚至当我接受上一份工作时，那是我感觉非常强烈的事情，嗯，你知道，我来自游戏行业，在游戏行业，如果你搞砸了，没那么重要，但是，但是如果你在工作，真的，它没有。这并不是说，你知道，游戏行业是一份艰苦的工作，也是一份值得的工作。但归根结底，它没有围绕它的那种道德担忧。是的。就像如果你发布的代码可能在几秒钟内损失数百万美元，
or could hurt someone if it goes wrong, right? Computerized operating theaters are a thing. You don't want to know what happens inside. them and what kind of you know because tech support exists and sometimes it is have you tried turning it off and on again in the middle of an operation i guess yeah i i definitely have never worked in a domain where i've had to worry about someone's life i mean i you're obviously completely correct about the the gaming industry you know there was a bunch of bugs and stuff that happened with cyberpunk 277 not that i never played it i just i like watching reviews online and people
或者如果出错可能会伤害某人，对吧？计算机化手术室是真实存在的。你不想知道里面发生了什么，以及什么样的，你知道，因为有技术支持，有时是“你试过关机再开机吗？”在手术过程中，我想，是的，我，我绝对从来没有在需要担心某人生命的地方工作过。我的意思是，你显然完全正确，关于游戏行业，你知道，Cyberpunk 2077 发生了一堆错误之类的，并不是我从来没玩过，我只是喜欢在线观看评论，人们，
getting upset and whatnot. But like, that was, that was the result of it, right? People post YouTube videos of, right? And, you know, maybe in the worst case, like someone's GPU gets overclocked and, you know, it's fried. But no one died, right? Like, it's not life and death, at least that I know of. And I'm not working, right now I don't work directly in that line, right? But I often think, you know, like if I went back and had my time again, I might choose to work in medical devices, you know, because that's an area of where it helps people. And that's just something that I think is good. You know, that's just my bias maybe on my leaning. But I don't, so I don't work directly on those things today.
感到不安之类的。但就像，那是，那是它的结果，对吧？人们发布 YouTube 视频，对吧？而且，你知道，也许在最坏的情况下，比如某人的 GPU 被超频，你知道，它烧毁了。但没有人死，对吧？就像，它不是生死攸关的，至少据我所知。而且我没有工作，现在我没有直接从事那一行，对吧？但我经常想，你知道，如果我回去，重新来过，我可能会选择在医疗设备领域工作，你知道，因为那是一个帮助人的领域。而且这只是我认为好的事情。你知道，那可能只是我的偏见，我的倾向。但我没有，所以我今天没有直接从事那些事情。
but I do work on kind of a substrate of things, which is used for all kinds of reasons, right? And so, you know, I work on power management inside the CPU. If my code goes wrong, CPU doesn't run, right? In extreme cases, the CPU burns itself up physically. Right. So we have to be absolutely sure that our code works and works correctly, right? Because of the use cases that things get put to, it could mean that someone's life is on the line. That is a very real possibility.
但我确实从事某种基质的东西，它被用于各种原因，对吧？所以，你知道，我从事 CPU 内部的电源管理。如果我的代码出错了，CPU 就无法运行，对吧？在极端情况下，CPU 会在物理上烧毁自己。对。所以我们必须绝对确定我们的代码能够工作，并且工作正确，对吧？由于事情被用于的用例，它可能意味着某人的生命危在旦夕。这是一个非常真实的可能性。
Be sure to check these show notes, either in your podcast app or at ADSP thepodcast.com, for links to anything we mentioned in today's episode, as well as a link to a get-up discussion where you can leave thoughts, comments, and questions. Thanks for listening. We hope you enjoyed and have a great day. I am the anti-brace. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
请务必查看这些节目笔记，无论是在你的播客应用程序中还是在 ADSPthepodcast.com 上，获取我们今天提到的任何内容的链接，以及一个 GitHub 讨论的链接，你可以在那里留下想法、评论和问题。感谢收听。我们希望你喜欢，祝你有美好的一天。我是反 Bryce。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来留下评论。